The greatest people
are self-managing.
They don’t need
to be managed.
If they know--
Once they know
what to do,
they’ll go figure out
how to do it,
and they don’t need
to be managed at all.
What they need
is a common vision,
and that’s what
leadership is.
What leadership
is having a vision,
being able to articulate that so the
people around you can understand it,
and getting a consensus
on a common vision.
We wanted people that were
insanely great at what they did,
but were not necessarily
those seasoned professionals,
but who had at the
tips of their fingers
and in their passion the latest
understanding of where technology was
and what we could do
with that technology,
and we wanted to bring
that to lots of people.
So the neatest thing
that happens
is when you get a core group of,
you know, ten great people,
it becomes self-policing as
to who they let into that group.
So I consider the most important job
of someone like myself is recruiting.
We agonized over hiring.
We had interviews.
I'd go back and look at some
of the interviews again.
They would start at 9:00 or 10:00 in
the morning and go through dinner.
A new interviewee would talk to
everybody in the building at least once
and maybe a couple times,
and then come back for
another round of interviews,
and then we’d all get together
and talk about it.
And then they'd fill
out an application.
[laughing]
No, they never filled out an application.
The critical part of the interview,
at least to my mind,
was when we finally decided
we liked them enough
to show them the
Macintosh prototype
and then we sat them
down in front of it.
If they were just kind of bored,
or said “This is a nice computer,”
we didn’t want them.
We wanted their
eyes to light up
and for them to
get really excited,
and then we knew
they were one of us.
And everybody
just wanted to work.
Not because it was work
that had to be done,
but it was because something
we really believed in
that was just going to
really make a difference.
And that’s what kept
the whole thing going.
We all wanted exactly
the same thing,
instead of spending our time arguing
about what the computer should be.
We all knew what
the computer should be,
and we just went
and did it.
We went through that stage in Apple
where we went out and thought oh,
we’re gonna be a big company,
let’s hire professional management.
We went out and hired a bunch
of professional management--
It didn’t work at all.
Most of them were bozos.
They knew how
to manage,
but they didn’t know
how to do anything!
And so, if you’re
a great person,
why do you want to work for somebody
you can’t learn anything from?
And you know
what’s interesting,
you know who the
best managers are?
They’re the great
individual contributors,
who never ever
want to be a manager,
but decide they
have to be a manager
because no one else is going to
be able to do as good a job as them.
[male narrator] After hiring two
professional managers
from outside the company
and firing them both,
Jobs gambled on Debby Coleman,
a member of the Macintosh team.
Thirty-two years old,
an English Literature major
with an MBA from Stanford,
Debbie was a financial manager
with no experience in manufacturing.
I mean, there’s no way
in the world anybody else
would give me this chance
to run this kind of operation,
and I don’t kid myself
about that.
It’s an incredible,
high risk
both for myself, personally
and professionally,
and for Apple
as a company,
to put a person like
myself in this job.
I mean, they’re really
betting on a lot of things.
We’re betting that my skills
at organizational effectiveness,
you know, override
all lack of technology,
lack of experience, lack of,
you know, time in manufacturing.
So, it’s a big risk,
and I’m just an example in every
single person on the Mac team,
almost to your
entry-level person,
you could say
that about.
This is a place where people were
afforded incredibly unique opportunities
to prove that they could do--
--they could write
the book again.
[narrator] Inscribed inside the
casing of every Macintosh,
unseen by the consumer,
are the signatures
of the whole team.
This is Apple’s way of affirming
that their latest innovation
is a product of the individuals
who created it,
not the corporation.